uh in Massachusetts we heard the
governor panicked and she wanted to
declare a state of emergency we know
what's going on in uh in New York City
where we've had a constant state of
emergency with over 125,000 illegal
aliens now factor in Illinois suddenly
the governor realized Chicago's overrun
so with these Suburban communities it is
an emergency what the hell is going on
with legal immigrant immigration at our
border this letter to uh President Biden
from maybe a future presidential
candidate Governor prit yeah he's a
Democrat keep in mind the letter says as
the numbers being transported to Chicago
are accelerating the humanitarian crisis
is overwhelming our ability to provide
Aid to The Refuge population to the
refugee population unfortunately the
welcome and Aid Illinois has been
providing to these Asylum Seekers has
not been matched with support by the
federal government most critically the
federal government's lack of
intervention and coordination at the
border has created an untenable
situation for Illinois sound familiar
and what he's complaining about is uh
Governor priser says look uh we are a
wash with migrants because we've had
15,000 in the last year that's how many
New York that's how many New York City
gets in a month and so Eagle Pass gets
in a day and so uh Governor pritsker
recommends that one person at the White
House lead the Border oversight uh also
he says it would be great one person
shouldn't Harris was to do that but
they've already got one person at the
White House secet right the Secretary of
Homeland Security he also suggests they
wave fees for applying for temporary
protective status so that it would be
easier migrants to get jobs and finally
and this is where while he says it's
untenable suddenly he's on the same page
of the White House he says uh Congress
needs to pass comprehensive immigration
reform which would be good but it's not
going to happen with this Congress and
so what they've got to do is this
Administration has got to figure a way
to fix what's going on so they want more
voters but they don't want to actually
address the root cause which is border
security making sure that the border
patrol can actually do their job instead
of doing processing but Brian it's
amazing that they are they're so
fustrated at what is happening as you
correctly noted and one day in Texas
Kathy Hogle is saying this is not a
complicated issue that the White House
just needs to do something and they the
blame let's
watch why don't you roll up your sleeves
and sit down at Democrats and get in the
room and don't come out until you figure
it out it's not that complicated I could
do it in about 5 minutes it's about
writing finding balance and putting the
resources out there for the borders but
also for for States like New York that
have extraordinary expenses managing the
crisis that's unfolding has the
president taken her call the president
refuses to meet with her but anytime
they try to parody and say we want to
get these people jobs that is the big
the big magnet don't buy that number two
is uh this President United States has
do not also say give me money for these
refugees that also is a problem I don't
want these cities to Flat with Federal
money of ours to keep these illegal
aliens getting their three meals a day
their mini menus and their laundry done
and their noses wiped not in our country
I love what New York city mayor ER Eric
Adams is doing he's doing what the Vice
President should be doing this guy is
going to Mexico City he's going to bogot
Columbia he's going to the Daran pass
he's going to meet with leaders and find
out what the problem is that's just it
you got to listen a lot of these a lot
of these Central American South American
countries have mad at us for making it
so easy to come in they are losing their
Workforce other times there's the
cartels more powerful than government
until you go down you don't know what
the issue is well what he's what he's
going to do is he's going to tell those
countries don't send your people because
we can't handle it Governor hokel said I
can fix the problem in five minutes but
here's the thing two days ago she said
the borders are the border is too open
got a lot of blowback uh they were
inquiring about that yesterday in the
briefing room at the White House and
after she said the border is too open
yesterday she amended it she walked it
all back and she said you know what we
really need is immigration reform yeah
they keep clarifying what they really
meant because they backlash she was
right the first time all right so an
advisor to the mayor of New York City
who is trying to find solutions for all
this cuz we're getting 100,000 migrants
we did at least in the last year his top
advisor ingred Lewis Martin was being
interviewed by a local news outlet and
said something very surprising saying we
need to this is a Democrat close the
borders listen
what the federal government needs to do
its job we need the federal government
the Congress members the Senate and the
president to do its job close The Bard
is well then after she said that after
she said that though a spokesman for
Eric Adams came back and said and
clarified the mayor believes the US
should continue to welcome immigrants
however Fabian uh Levy says there need
to be dep decompression strategies at
the border that's what does that mean a
national border security uh
comprehensive reform and that's not
going to happen and they they all know
it especially with because the main
thing is is the main issue was what do
you do with the people here you don't
even you don't even touch that until you
seal the Border and now the issue is
going to be even more dynamic because
you have doubled the number of illegals
in our country and then if you
hermetically seal the Border deal with
the Central and South American issues
get Mexico to enforce their border by
the way because they're now saying that
they're they're more than ever are
coming right through then you do all
that and then you consider the people
here already that's how far away from
comprehensive also it's not healthy when
the White House accuses Republicans are
pulling a political stunt that's all a
political stunt they were not
Republicans these are Dem Democrats the
reason why they're saying this now
though Brian is because it's election
time and right now the leading front
runner is Donald Trump which this was
his signature issue when you look at the
New York Times today they know the
expose about what Donald Trump wanted to
do with the cartel and the finau that he
wanted to go after the Mexican Gams and
the drug lords there they're I just
think it's a big problem for the next
presidential election and it's going to
only help him with independent voters
well nonetheless there are a bunch of
Democrats who are now drawing attention
to it saying hey Mr President do
something while in the meantime the
phone is ringing at the White House and
nobody's picking it up and they're
thinking well we're just going to live
off the row V8 I don't think so not in
2024 that much I'm Steve duy I'm Brian
kilme and I'm Angley aart and click here
to subscribe to the Fox News YouTube
page to catch our hottest interviews and
most compelling
analysis